hey how you doing okay
I'm here to turn myself in okay what's
going on I had an accident last night
okay
showing an old friend of mine how to use
this gun that she was needing that she
asked for and it went off and it shot
her in the chest
and I've been running around scared
up on Miami Montgomery County Line Road
okay usually set your water right there
sure
no okay just put your hands behind your
back for me
I'm just gonna detain you right now
based off what you're telling me right
you want to talk to me I'll still talk
to you
okay all right all right is this person
needing Assistance or help or you have
two sets of cuffs I can put two sets on
in a second okay does this person need
help right now or are they deceased or
what they're deceased does anybody else
know about this
I don't know okay
where where is this address actually
that you you're at I don't know the
actual number is this her house or your
house
what what county is it in it's on the
Miami County side but it's on Miami
Montgomery County Line Road
mommy's for 311. I'll be in the back lot
with one
uh can you do a miscellaneous call if I
have one to change I think you uh start
310.
watching after I'm Brian Brian I'm I'm
also doing I'm just gonna check check
you down go right ahead
I'm in the back a lot of the beauty in
the parking lot
okay again no weapons on you right right
not even a pocket knife no okay
now that I left that in the truck okay
Brian what's your last name Brian Mason
is there a weapon in your truck yeah
okay
oh you dropped a quarter okay
yeah this is hurting my back okay I'll
turn it yeah when you're done hit you up
for one second okay when you feel safe
absolutely
yeah because I wouldn't be here
voluntarily
but I've been so scared since it
happened okay uh what's uh what's your
social security Brian
what's uh
Lobster small
all right let's have a seat in my car
for two seconds and I'll switch to
California okay
[Applause]
all right hop up there it's a big big
step just give me one second what what's
your last name again Mason Mason or
paper
yeah yeah just give me one second okay
okay
come on this guy walks up he's like
okay what's going on
I said hey I'm just here to turn myself
on said for what he said uh excellent
shot killed someone last night
so he says that he was at a
on County Line Road doesn't know the
exact address said he was shown to
friend at gun and it went off and shot
her on the chest and she's deceased I
said there's this person need assistance
they need help or are they deceased he
said they're deceased
so I detained them
I said hey if you want to talk to me
we're sitting on on what you're telling
me and I'll read you Miranda you know
and talk to you but you said there's a
guy in his car I haven't confirmed
that's the gun he used he doesn't even
know the address at this point
oh God
so
okay yep so you're the perfect guy to be
in charge right now so
I'm gonna read the Moran down and see if
we'll keep talking he said he wants
another pair of cuffs on I think that's
I'll just put another set on if he's
ready to keep talking to me at this
point
so I he said it's like I'm a Montgomery
County Miami County Florida
all right we're going to try to find out
where this happened
[Applause]
even though hop on let's put the other
repair cuffs on you okay thank you yeah
I don't think that you're causing any
problems just just obviously you came in
when he talked to us tell us about this
all right just relax relax
foreign
[Music]
police officer sheriff's deputy you are
here by advice you have certain rights
as follows you have the right to remain
silent you don't have to make any
statements or answer any questions you
understand yeah okay anything you say
Cannonball music instrument court of law
do you understand yes okay
if you cannot afford I'm sorry you have
the right to speak with a lawyer for
advice before you're asked any questions
you have the right to have a lawyer with
you during any questions you understand
yes yes okay if you cannot afford a
lawyer a lawyer appointed by the court
or a lawyer from the public defender's
office will be provided to you before
and during any question without any
costs you understand yes if you decide
to answer any questions now without a
lawyer present you will still have the
right to stop answering at any time you
also have the right to stop answering
anytime until you talk with a lawyer do
you understand yes okay now that you
understand your rights are you willing
to answer any questions without a lawyer
president
um minimum I mean okay to be fair
representation is needed but at the bare
minimum we're trying to figure out right
to address this person needs help you're
telling us they're beyond help at this
point so but she collects instantly
and I got scared I got frightened and
ran out
Brian Nathan
Ryan he asked a question when we do need
to a yes or no on that you can you can
refuse to answer any question we asked
and you can stop answering at any time
like you read you so if you say minimal
I mean we need to know if you want a
lawyer or if you're willing to answer
some questions
you can always refuse to answer any
question that you want to refuse to
answer you know I appreciate you guys
thank you very much
yes at this time I can answer some
questions
um first of all let me ask you this has
this been reported to law enforcement at
all no this is it I'm walking in because
I know this is the right thing to do
but where do you live at I've been
living out of my truck in motel rooms
since I quit my trucking job I'm just
trying to figure out why you came to
this Police Department driving around
yeah I've been all over the place okay
where did this happen
up on the Miami Montgomery County Line
Road
you have an address I don't know her
house number what's her name I think
it's in the 9000 series
okay
um her name is Michelle Elliott
what's her age approximately 57 same age
as me I've noticed is this is this her
address
she lives on in the 9000 block of Miami
County Line Road and her name's Michelle
Elliott what kind of cars are in the
driveway yeah none there's none what
does the house look like if you could
describe it to me so I could describe
somebody else three bedroom
like what color is the garage door
wait I pulled up like Google Maps or
something did you even showing him I
guess
yeah
do you mind will you come downstairs to
the interview room with us
one more time is that cool with you yeah
okay yeah no anything to make you feel
safe okay no problem I just want to make
sure that you don't have a gun you said
it was one of the cars so I just want to
make sure you don't have any other
weapons
all right
so we'll find out where it happens okay
I know we can get this taken care of
I'm too scared of what the system's
gonna do to me I'm not scared of you
guys
I'm just gonna grab your stuff and bring
it down
okay what kind of truck did you come in
you said there's a truck
okay
is this the weapon that you used yes
[Music]
okay all right come on staying up here
just keep an eye on them yep
they're not gonna have that crew respond
to the uh public lot on Second Street
thank you
311 could you have plate to the call
please
this guy just walked up to me and said
he shot and killed somebody
oh I guess so I'm on by the way so he
said the gun he used to kill her with
isn't this car or accidentally
so
Justin wants you to sit in this car
we're trying to figure out where this
happened he doesn't know the address
no
but he said huh
no Justin's with him right now he says
in this corner so Jessa said you need to
sit with the car so
can you get
um a property bag real quick so we can
throw all this stuff in there
and let's switch to records
yeah and you just walk in the back lot
so
Justin wanted a messy
mommy for 311 for a while
all right
add both a call for me
and I have a question for you break
can you try to find a Michelle Elliott
both common spelling and leads and her
age is around 57 and she lives in the 9
000 block of County Line Road
I'm not sure if that's in Montgomery
County or if that's in Miami County
[Music]
[Applause]
you can run it don't tell me you can't
all right don't go in the car just sit
here with it
all right
foreign
[Music]
County Sheriff's Office
okay thank you sure
you stay with them
I'm gonna see what I'm finding though
like um
foreign
[Music]
November I think I'm not sure do you
know about what year
oh yeah um
66.
mommy's for 3 11. can you try
November 1st 1966 on that Michelle
Elliott
yeah sorry we knew we never exchanged
cards and stuff like that
so you don't live on uh Soldiers Home
anymore no I do not okay gotcha
yeah I've been uh
I was living in my truck
and then after um
my health started failing and I couldn't
keep a med card because my blood
pressure was too high yeah I quit and
then took my savings and
just been staying in rooms
or in my drawer
okay I gotcha
I could do for you staying at that house
with her yeah would she let you stay
there or not well she offered but
because of her
debilitating disease
I couldn't it was it was too tough to be
around her but it was too tough to be
around her when she'd be thrown to die
I don't drink and I don't take pills
so
so that's what we argued about all the
time you know if it wasn't if I ignored
it it was fine but I had to put up with
the way she acts when she was under the
influence
yeah so
now I'm getting pretty dry mouth
you want to order sure all right let me
get your water be right back okay thank
you
let me just shut the door if you need
something just knock on it be like two
seconds okay
thank you
hey Justin
she's he said that he thinks she's born
in 66.
um we asked him for a middle name did
you know middle name um I'll go ask he
said believes November something 66.
dispatch can't find anything
hard to try to run on records
I'm gonna get him a water
okay
all right here's your water for you
thank you do you know her middle name by
any chance no I don't you don't okay but
you said it's a brick ranch white garage
door right does it have like is it like
way off the road is it close no close to
the road and it's approximately
maybe a half a mile
to three quarters of a mile east of
state route 49.
okay I'm sorry to say that again you
said it's about three quarters yes of a
mile East
and be on the Miami County side the
north side of the road east of
Phillipsburg north of Phillipsburg but
east of what road I'm sorry oh state
route 49. 49
okay give me one second I'm trying to
pull up an image of it okay
okay
he said it's like
hey Ashley I'm local
yeah
can you respond back to the PD and come
to the basement to the interview rooms
I'm so I'm still recording by the way um
he said he thinks it's a three-fourths
of a mile east of 49.
County Line Road
foreign
[Music]
um the other officer here asked for her
phone number oh he did and we need it
yeah
it's our little competing back and forth
What's um what do you want to pull
Google Maps I'll show you let me get her
phone number again real quick so sorry
if you got it I'm sorry you know her
phone number yeah let me just write it
down real quick it's 937
-5778
oh
yeah I'm gonna see if I pull up a
picture here so I'll show you
hey if you want me to I can try to have
the dispatch server to do emergency